you darvish is up
on the mount the soon to be 35 year old
and all-star this year for the first
time since 2017 but
not nearly as sharp since the start of
july
the payoff from darvish check swing and
appeal
and they say that it goes darvish going
with the off speed pitch and you see it
down in the zone and
bill miller over at third when asked
brings him up he's ahead 02 to pavon
smith
and gets him on three pitches darvish
strikes out the first two diamondbacks
hitters that he faces
on the ground over towards the shift and
an easy play there for frazier
darvish retires his side in order hitler
widener is
up on the hill today for the
diamondbacks fastball slider change
guy and he started off here he was
pitching pretty well went on the
disabled list and since he's come back
he's just been inconsistent
blows it right past him and fam strikes
out to begin the home first
here he just rears back right now and
goes with that four seamer and
fam unable to catch up to it just
underneath it
this is laced out towards left center
field and back on the warning track
practically pavon smith
hauls it in for round number two two
outs nobody on scoreless in the bottom
of the first inning and manny machado
will stand in
three two hit in the air a mile deep to
left field will it stay fair
it will drop out for the western metal
way out of here
manny machado with his 21st of the
season he adds to that under 30 hit
total
and the padres take a one-nothing lead
in the first putting it back
hanging slider comes in at 83 miles per
hour leaves at 108.
ninth pitch of the at-bat certainly one
widener once back
and he didn't even hit this ball as good
as he possibly could he's out front
but still got it up in that third deck
at the top of one another cole calhoun
leads it off for the diamondbacks
golfed out towards right field myers has
to play it on a bounce
and calhoun a leadoff single that brings
up left fielder david peralta
swings through a third strikeout for
darvish so now the right-handed hitter
kristen walker will get in there first
one that you will face
this is crunched out towards left center
he
leans into it and gone off the facade
walker's fifth it's a two-run job and he
has put the snakes in front
don't forget about me in 2022. he says
again that's what 28 109 off the bat
right i mean that ball was absolutely
crushed and
see that thing just absolutely
annihilated
four seamer just right on the inner part
of the plate darvish misses his spot
and walker does not miss it he is very
late on a fastball here in strike zone
that's the fourth for garbage two in
each of the first couple of minutes
one two swung on and tipped into the
catchers mate strike three
boy five strikeouts and two innings for
garbage as we take you to the bottom of
the second that's where eric hosmer
leads things off
swings at the first pitch it just skies
one deep to right field headed towards
the pole that one
is gonna go a long home run deep into
the lower level down the right
field line and eric cosmo with his ninth
home run of the season
a towering shot and this game is tied
two to two in the second
the ball is hammered it looked like it
hit
near the top of the foul pole as it came
down
right down that right field line padres
get even here two to two on an eric
hosmer home run
his ninth of the season 50th rbi
garvish has seven strikeouts over three
innings dribble cabrera leads it off for
the diamondbacks
that is strikeout number eight for
darvish there's your uh splitter again
there
i haven't featured that often but when
he does
it's effective you see this thing just
drops out of the zone now the pitch
and a swing of the miss strikeout number
nine for you darvish
as he gets christian walker to end the
top of the fourth inning
bases are loaded a couple of walks in a
single this is popped up
ahmed makes a routine catch
and the one-two pitch to him is grounded
as short ahmed's got it
flips to sing for one and then on to
first and that is
and any nanny double play padres had the
bases loaded and nobody out
but caratini popped out and then darvish
grounds into a double play
to handy in it
strikeout number 10 for darvish 10
punch-outs over four and two-thirds
here's that slider it drops out of the
zone there
another swinging strike three 11
strikeouts for darvish
over five innings as he blows it past
widener
now for weiner now third time through
the order and strike three call got him
looking
and that's another strikeout number six
of the night for weiner and a good way
to start the fifth
fam didn't like the call but it was a
slider just kind of stayed right there
hung right on the outside corner but he
got the call
strike three call taylor widener
carves right through fam frazier and
mcconnell
darvish 11 strikeouts over five innings
swing and a miss strike three a dozen
strikeouts for you darvish that matches
his season high
we haven't seen him very often aaron but
here he goes right after him with the
fastball
blows it right by smith rookie tyler
gilbert back out there to work the home
seventh in a two-two tie into left field
for a base hit
grisham a lead off single the padres
have to go ahead run aboard to begin the
last of the seventh swing and a miss
goes right through caratini on three
pitches
back to the mound gilbert has it fires
to second
on to first all kinds of time for the
double play
to end the seventh pomeranz takes over
he will work the eighth
big chop off the plate machado
fair hand to first with a rocket throw
in time
i mean that's sick that is just sick
coming in
you know ahmed's a decent runner it's a
high chopper he knows he's gonna have to
do or die he bare hands it on a hop and
then fires it over there
i mean the athleticism that machado has
you
couple that with the arm strength i mean
you know it's it's why he's a 300
million dollar player
so now the go ahead run in scoring
position and manny coming up
due to machado into center field and
drops in frazier's coming home
and who else but manny machado has put
the friars in front
in the bottom of the eighth i mean
machado really does a great job first of
taking put himself in a two-strike hole
and then fighting off this hanger knows
he doesn't have to do too much with it
just shoots it out to center field
doesn't hit hard
well now bags packed now here's the
payoff just off the plate a bases loaded
walk and a two-run lead for the padres
austin nola bats for caratini on the
first pitch into right field for a base
hit cronin worth is in
myers comes peddling home right behind
him into third base grisham is
safe a two-run pitch it single for nola
and all of a sudden it's six to two
padres in
situation but jace tingler's not messing
around he had malanson up and warming
he's got him coming in
to work tonight another 3-2 ground ball
onto second to first double play
here's the pitch to calhoun he kind of
muscles it over to the right side
short hop stop by frazier runs it most
of the way to first
underhand flip to hosmer in the ball
game is over mark bellanson works a
scoreless ninth inning
and the padres use a four run eight to
even this series up
a 6-2 win over the diamondbacks